recently we started a new site Conan
Triple X all right so far we have
debuted to Conan xxx videos on the site
one girl 20 pencils that was pretty
amazing and one guy two bowls featuring
our own Andy Richter eating two bowls of
soup yeah I have regrets yeah never seen
you so filled with shame well or soup
well tonight tonight we've got another
Conan xxx video to show you it's called
please do the crossword with my wife
enjoy all right thanks for coming by and
doing this what are your names
I'm Jose Lori about two years about two
years we like to do crosswords together
proposal to go yeah today I understand
that you have a bit of a request and
that is that you would like Jose to
watch you do a crossword puzzle with
another
the meeting - Drock yeah I mean if it
makes Larry happy we'd like you to meet
someone Laurie Dion why don't you come
on in here
Laurie this is beyond I would say
watching you scoot on over a little bit
there give them give them some room so
they can do the crossword
it wasn't once you move on over to the
school next to the that's great you guys
just take the Senators account there to
meet you dr. cross word puzzle Jose just
sit back and relax and enjoy the show
[Music]
forty-eight across to be a real good be
ring right the ring it wouldn't be right
yeah you've done this before
again this is a this is a real site so
go check it out at conan dot XXX
[Applause]